I think we live in a culture in which
there's so much energy behind
distracting us whether it's video games
or movies or Netflix or alcohol or
whatever you know pick your drug or
gambling whatever it is
we're never bored we have a super
computer in our pocket that can keep our
mind occupied at all times and you
actually have to muster almost
an innate superpower to get still and
honest with yourself to live and sit
with your feelings you have to go out of
your way to do that but in truth that's
the only way in which the truth of your
circumstances is going to become evident
to you absolutely and you've hit the
nail on the head right and this is
essentially what we're trying to do for
people in many ways because you only
discover that I think when you remove
the alcohol and gabometer I know is good
friend of yours and I've been lucky
enough to train with him has that that
saying not why the problem why the pain